well you've written about jira dreams of
sushi
um it's just a really clean good example
that people are aware of
of mastery in the
in the art of the simple in food uh
what do you make of that kind of
obsessive pursuit of perfection in
in in creating simple food sushi is
about perfection
but it's a bit like the beatles white
album which people think is simple
and not overproduced yeah it's in a
funny way their most
overproduced album but it's produced
just perfectly it sounds simple
it's really hard to produce music to the
point where it's going to sound so
simple
and not sound like sludge like let it be
album
there's some great songs but a lot of it
sounds like sledge one after 909
that's sludge i dig a pony sludge like
it's a bit interesting
it's not that good it doesn't sound that
good white album like the best half like
dear prudence
sounds perfect sounds simple crybaby cry
it's not simple back in the ussr super
complex
so sushi's like that it's because it's
so incredibly not simple starting with
the rice
you try to refine it to make it appear
super simple and that's the most complex
thing of all
so do you admire i mean
we're not talking about days weeks
months
we're talking about years generations of
doing the same thing over and over and
over again
do you admire that kind of sticking to
the it does that
you know we talked about our admiration
of the weird
that doesn't feel weird that seems like
discipline
and dedication to like like a stoic
minimalism or something like that i'm
happy they do it but i actually feel bad
about it
i feel they're sacrificial victims to me
which i benefit from
but don't you ever think like gee you're
a great master
sushi chef wouldn't you be happier if
you did something else
uh doesn't seem to happen that might be
something that a weird mind
maybe it is weird people and maybe
they're really enjoying it
but like to learn how to pack rice for
ten years before they let you do
anything else
it's like these indian you know sarod
players they just spent five years
tapping out rhythms
before they're allowed to touch their
instruments
well actually to to defend that it's
kind of like graduate school right
well i think graduate school perhaps
i um graduate school is full of like
every single day is full of surprises i
would say
i i did martial arts for a long time i
do martial arts
and i've always loved it's kind of the
russian way of drilling
is doing the same technique i don't know
if this
applies in into intellectual or academic
disciplines where you can do the same
thing over and over and over again
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times
what i've discovered through that
process
is you get to start to appreciate the
tiniest of details and find the beauty
in them
people who go to like monasteries to
meditate talk about this
is when you just sit in silence and
don't do anything
you start to appreciate how much
complexity and beauty there isn't just a
movement of a finger like you can spend
the whole day
joyously thinking about how fun it is to
move a finger
yeah and so and then you can almost
become
your full weird self about the tiniest
details of life
that's the thing you've got to wonder
like is there a free lunch in there are
the rest of us moving around too much
yeah exactly that's they sure
feel like they found a free lunch the
people meditate they're on to something
i tend to think it's like artists that
some percent of people are like that but
most are not
and for most of us there's no free lunch
like my free lunch is to move around a
lot
in search of lunch in fact well you with
all the food talk it made me hungry
you